it has been one week since Hurricane
Emma first hit the Caribbean at least 37
people killed there st. John one of the
United States Virgin Islands may
represent hermas worst impact on
American soil turning to copal went
there to talk with survivors this
morning he's in San Juan Puerto Rico
Tony good morning good morning San Juan
has become a lifeline between here and
the US Virgin Islands and we followed
that lifeline to st. John where well it
looks like winter it is not a lush
tropical island now everything is brown
and the damage is nearly atomic at Cruz
Bay which should be bustling with
tourists there is very little stirring
after most of the island has evacuated
take a look we need to let everybody
know how bad it is here Tommy young
moved from Boston and made Coral Bay
sing John his home in 2007 we're on the
other side of the island were totally
devastated we've lost homes we lost
rules we lost vehicles what if your home
look like it's gone yeah it's gone irma
hit the Virgin Islands as a category 5
hurricane with 150 mile an hour winds
the storm changed the 20 square mile
landscape of Saint John stripping the
leaves off trees and making the hillside
look charred as we sailed into the
islands largest town cruise Bay we saw
that even the u.s. customs office was a
total loss it is a ghost town in an area
that would typically be bustling with
tourists everything is still with the
exception of construction aid workers
and recently members of the US Navy who
are here now to restore order
nearly every building on the island is
damaged or destroyed and this is what an
advance team from FEMA saw Tuesday as
they surveyed the island for a command
post you're sure there's nothing else on
the island other than this room right
here standing that will be usable okay
I'm dead serious yeah roughly 5000
people live on st. John and Island in
American hands for a hundred years you
live here at your Island it's your
Island also this is your home yeah but
guess what we have no control over it
it's gonna take time but we'll be back
paradise will be back
we're down but not out Tommy Young told
me he is grateful even if his next steps
are unclear we are there are people like
myself we've lost everything closed on
me back from others
these are borrowed yeah what's it gonna
take for you to get back on your feet
for this island to get back on its feet
lots of prayers you know just some time
lots of healing now there there is good
news you saw the Navy is there now FEMA
is on the ground now there are fairies
armed with guards to make sure the
resources get where they need to go
moving from st. Thomas to st. John but
no matter how you cut it no matter you
look at it this is going to be a
recovery measured in years but we heard
again and again a recovery will come
Paradise will be back Charlie thank you
Tony